hola buenos días pues hace tan sólo unos
minutos
salió de la oficina de abogados ubicada
en el centro de melbourne donde estaba
esperando las 4 horas que tenía el
gobierno federal para volver a
detenerlos sin embargo el gobierno
federal aún puede cancelar su visa e
incluso deportar nos espera que mañana
más tardar el ministro de inmigración
tome esa decisión pero uno de los
principales motivos para fallar
y las indicadas
medianoche no tuvo suficiente para
asesorarse con sus abogados que se
habían cultivado principalmente la
decisión del cuenta decisión se tuvo
hasta el 5 directo de la tarde ahora
local aquí en las instalaciones de la
corte federal donde desde muy tempranas
horas estaban esperándolo principalmente
personas de serbia que muestran su apoyo
que estaban mostrándose a favor del
deportista el fallo del juez también
ordenó la devolución inmediata de su
pasaporte y además que el gobierno
federal asuma los costos de la defensa
de yogur y yoko noche entonces ahora
puede estar con hindús verde por ahora
para disputar el abierto de australia y
defender su título recordemos que
djokovic busca ganar su décimo título
del conjunto de la australia y su
vigésimo primer título delante están
para superar a rafael nadal o jesse
también se espera que en unas horas se
sepa en definitiva donde va a estar
alojado djokovic se sabe que usualmente
cuando viene a mi álbum enfrenta una
propiedad privada por la cancha de tenis
es muy probable que hasta ahora se esté
dirigiendo para allá porque también el
juez por qué no que ya no estuviera en
el hotel de inmigración